hey leute und zwar habe ich vor zwei bis
drei monaten ein angebot bekommen für
den fernsehsender kicker zu arbeiten
wahrscheinlich haben manche von euch
sogar schon ein teil meiner arbeit
gesehen und fernsehen wie das ganze
zustande gekommen ist er gleich in
diesem video wahrscheinlich schauen die
meisten von euch sowieso kein fernsehen
aber vielleicht kennen der eine oder
andere die sendung die beste klasse
deutschlands und dem tv werden diese
sendungen ja immer einige tage zuvor
beworben in dem fall nämlich genau
sieben tage in eine woche vor
ausstrahlung sollte jeden tag ein
kleiner werbeclip laufen in dem auf
spielerische art und weise erwähnt wird
dass sie zum beispiel in zwei drei oder
einem tag losgeht
moment ich zeige euch mal dass es in
fünf tagen ist es soweit
[Musik]
sie verstehe es wird magisch
morgen geht es los die beste klasse
deutschlands und für die maschinen
diesen tipps fertigzustellen ich nicht
das ganze mit geli geregelt hat erklärt
später jetzt möchte ich euch jetzt mal
zeigen wie ich die effekte in den clubs
gemacht habe falls ihr euch an dieser
stelle fragen wieso das schon ein
komisches flasche steht der reisende
mikrofon dran
der clip den ich euch zeigen möchte ist
folgender und zwar packt der moderator
der also erstmal verschiedene dinge in
eine papiertüte viertel diese papiertüte
aber kräftig haut sie auf den tischen
wie durch magie erscheint also die titel
wieder hoch hebt die 27 das original
filmmaterial wohl so aufgenommen dass
man natürlich erstmal ganz normal
einfach diese ganzen gegenstände in die
tüte rein gemacht hat und dann auf den
tisch gehauen hat danach befindet sich
das zeug natürlich immer noch unter der
tüte und da ist keine sieben plötzlich
deswegen musste der mann im vordergrund
gerade die tüte wegnehmen aus lehrern
und die zahl sieben darunter stellen und
dann konnte man zu weitermachen die tüte
hochheben und die zahl 7 ist runter wenn
man jetzt quasi den teil wo die zahl
sieben reingeschmuggelt wird entfernt
sieht das ganze so aus und das sieht man
natürlich einen heftigen schnitt vor
allem wenn man jetzt mal ins gesicht
welche sich komplett verändert oder auch
die schulter da im hintergrund die in
der zweiten hälfte viel weiter hinten
als in der ersten
auch was ich tue ist verändert sich
alles komplett da musste natürlich
einiges getan würden zu allgemeinen
erklärung wie ich davor gegangen bin
also wir haben ja zwei clips einmal den
erster und einmal den zweiten und ich
habe quasi versucht dass ich den ersten
clip langsam so verzehre und verschiebe
dass er am ende so aussieht wie der
zweite clip am anfang aussieht und der
schnitt dadurch dann natürlich möglichst
unsichtbar bleibt hier zum beispiel
sieht man ja ganz deutlich dass sich der
prozess ohne ecke in der tüte hervortut
welche in der zweiten hälfte da ist aber
in den ersten natürlich noch nicht
deswegen habe ich einfach in die erste
hälfte so eine kleine ecke hier dazu
geschummelt und jetzt erkennt man
natürlich im schnitt immer noch aber es
ist auf jeden fall schon mal ein guter
schritt in die richtige richtung was ich
noch ziemlich stark verändert ist dass
die tüte dann im zweiten clip plötzlich
scharf ist und sich hatte schatten
abzeichnen deswegen habe ich eigentlich
die tüte aus der zweiten hälfte aus
maskiert und über die tüte in der ersten
hälfte gelegt und dadurch sieht so aus
als würde quasi diese harte schatten nur
langsam entstehen und nicht ruckartig
danach wollte ich ein bisschen so
aussehen lassen als würde seine hand
nicht einfach so auf das abprallen doch
noch ein bisschen nach unten gehen dafür
habe ich einerseits die hüte aus
maskiert und etwas nach unten verschoben
und aber auch noch ein bisschen unscharf
gemacht damit es eben so aussieht als
würde sich die tüte sehr schnell bewegen
anschließend habe ich den unterarm aus
maske und lebenswegen gedreht dass du
ein bisschen nach unten drückt dort auch
noch unschärfe hinzugefügt und dann
natürlich auch noch den oberarm
angepasst und jetzt sieht schon so aus
als würde der abend so ein bisschen nach
unten drücken und wenn man jetzt mal auf
die füße guckt dann ist der schnitt
schon viel viel unauffälliger aber
natürlich ist der rest immer noch sehr
sehr offensichtlich wird zum beispiel
das gesicht oder die schulträger ein
werkzeug was sich dabei sehr sehr häufig
verwendet haben ist das für flüssigen
werkzeug damit kann man eben stellen im
video verzerren und verschieben wie
jetzt hier zum beispiel den korb oder
die schulter hier jetzt zum beispiel ein
bisschen reinschieben oder hier raus
schieben und dann kann man natürlich den
effekt auch langsam aus und an machen
wie hier jetzt zum beispiel in diesem
clip habe ich den effekt schon auf malta
oberkörper angewendet so dass er sich
quasi im ersten clip langsam so verzehrt
wie er im zweiten aussehen wird
natürlich fehlt dann noch das wichtigste
und zwar der kopf der sich ja in den
beiden clips ganz stark ändert dafür
habe ich den kopf einfach ausgeschnitten
und eben langsam auch so wie ich ihn
haben möchte und dass sie ihr seht zum
mikro sich aus deswegen habe ich noch
einen weiteren trick angewendet und zwar
habe ich einfach den kopf aus der 2
genommen so wir quasi letztendlich
aussehen soll in der ersten hälfte und
ging quasi rückwärts verzerrt so dass er
sich glück wird so verändert werde
vorjahr und dadurch haben wir jetzt eben
auch beim kopf ein relativ weich mit
übergang dann müssten noch verschiedene
kleinigkeiten gemacht werden wie diese
jacke die sich natürlich hier komplett
auffällig verändert welche ich dann so
bearbeitet habe dass sie sich eben
verändert oder kleinere details man
fragen wie diese schatten hier zum
beispiel und dann ist der x te
eigentlich auch schon soweit fertig
durch die verzerrungen die ich auf
meinte angewendet habe sieht man
natürlich auch im hintergrund wie sich
zum beispiel diese bilder verändert das
wollen wir natürlich nicht deswegen habe
ich diesen club jetzt in dem ich heute
schon so frais zvs herausgenommen haben
heute daraus ausgeschnitten und haben
dann quasi einfach über ein bild des
hintergrunds gelegt in dem heute gar
nicht fern dass wir sie zum beispiel
dass ich diese tüte hier bild für bild
aus maskiert habe diese grauen kästchen
im hintergrund bedeuten übrigens dass
das an dieser stelle durchsichtig ist 30
kann den hintergrund auch einfach grün
machen oder natürlich für unseren fall
viel sinnvoller den hintergrund blenden
danach habe ich nacheinander die
einzelnen körperteile aus maskiert wie
zum beispiel diesen abend wie den bauch
wie die hose natürlich den tisch und
letztendlich den kopf wenn ich gemeint
wäre könnte ich natürlich malte jetzt
auch in die sahara setzen habe ich will
mal nicht so sein deswegen setzen wir
wieder zurück in den drehort da der
hintergrund natürlich jetzt einfach nur
ein bild ist fällt natürlich kein
schatten darauf der normalerweise von
malte kommen müsste deswegen habe ich
den mal nur noch ein maskiert und dann
sind auch schon fertig ihr seht ihr im
alter aktiv verschiedene dinge in die
tüte schüttelt ordentlich heute auf den
tisch zieht sie wieder nach oben und die
zahl 7 ist da so das war's soweit für
diesen kleinen einblick und jetzt zu
reden ich war natürlich nicht aufhören
zu arbeiten ich habe immer noch über
bock drauf aber da ich ja nicht fest
angestellt sind sondern schreibe
wirklich kann ich natürlich nebenbei
noch andere aufträge annehmen sofern ich
dafür zeit was ist meistens nicht weil
es aber in dem fall az kurz
zusammengefasst und dadurch ist diese
coole arbeiten statt ich hoffe euch hat
das video gefallen wenn ihr mich auf
dieser reise begleiten wollen und nichts
mehr verpassen möchtest dann abonniert
auf diesem kanal und dann sehen wir es
beim nächsten mal wieder nachts gut
[Musik]